[Applause]
there's a lot of it this is seaweed it's
um it's pretty humble stuff but it does
have some remarkable qualities for one
it grows really fast so the carbon that
is part of that seaweed just a few weeks
ago was floating in the atmosphere as
atmospheric co2 driving all the adverse
consequences of climate change for the
moment it's locked safely away in the
seaweed but when that seaweed rots and
by the smell of it it's not far away
when it rots that co2 will be released
back to the atmosphere wouldn't it be
fantastic if we could find a way of
keeping that co2 locked up long-term and
thereby significantly contributing to
the climate to solving the climate
problem what I'm talking about here is
drawdown it's now become the other half
of the climate challenge and that's
because we have delayed so long in terms
of addressing climate change that we now
have to do two very big and very
difficult things at once we have to cut
our emissions and clean our energy
supply at the same time that we draw
significance of carbon dioxide out of
the atmosphere if we don't do that about
25 percent of the co2 we put in the air
will remain there by human standards
forever so we have to act this is really
a new phase in addressing the climate
crisis and it demands new thinking so
your ideas like carbon offsets really
don't make sense in the modern era you
know when you offset something you say
I'll permit myself to put some
greenhouse gas into the atmosphere but
then I'll offset it by drawing it down
when you've got to both cut your
emissions and draw down co2 that
thinking doesn't make sense anymore and
when we're talking about drawdown we're
talking about putting large volumes of
greenhouse gases particularly co2 out of
circulation and to do that we need a
carbon price we need a significant price
that will pay for that service that will
all benefit from where they'd almost no
progress so far with the second half of
the climate challenge it's not on most
people's radar and you know I must say
at times I hear people saying I've lost
hope that we can do anything about the
climate crisis and look like I've had my
sleepless nights too I can tell you but
I'm I'm here today as an ambassador for
this humble weed sea weed it is really I
think it has the potential to be a big
part of our challenge of addressing a
challenge of climate change and a big
part of their future now what the
scientists are telling us we need to do
over the next 80 odd years to the end of
this century is to cut our greenhouse
gas emissions by 3% every year and draw
three Giga tons of co2 out of the
atmosphere every year those numbers are
so bad that they baffle us but that's
what the scientists tell us we need to
do
I really hate showing this graph but I'm
sorry I have to do it
it is very eloquent in terms of telling
the story of my personal failure in
terms of all the advocacy I've done in
climate change work and in fact our
collective failure to address climate
change you can see our trajectory there
in terms of warming and greenhouse gas
concentrations you can see all of the
great scientific announcements that
we've made saying how much danger we
face with climate change you can see the
political meetings none of it has
changed the trajectory and this is why
we need new thinking we need a new
approach so how might we go about
drawing down greenhouse gases at a large
scale there's really only two ways of
doing it and I've done a very deep dive
in
to drawdown and i'll preempt my and now
so did this stuff comes out smelling
comes up smelling like roses the end of
the day it does it's one of the best
options but there are many many
possibilities there are chemical
pathways and biological pathways so two
ways really of getting the job done the
biological pathways are fantastic
because the energy source that's needed
to drive them the Sun is effectively
free we use the Sun to drive
photosynthesis in plants break apart
that co2 and capture the carbon there
are also chemical pathways they sound
ominous but actually they're not bad at
all the difficulty they face is that we
have to actually pay for the energy
that's required to do the job or pay to
facilitate that energy direct air
capture is a great example of a chemical
pathway and people are using that right
now to take co2 out of the atmosphere
and manufacture biofuels or manufacture
plastics great progress is being made
but it will be many decades before those
chemical pathways are drawing down a
Giga ton of co2 a year the biological
pathways offer us a lot more hope I
think in the short term you've probably
heard about reforest ation planting
trees as a solution to the climate
problem you know ken it's a fair
question can we plant our way out of
this problem by using trees I am
skeptical about that for a number of
reasons one is just the scale of the
problem I mean all trees status seeds
little tiny things that it's many
decades before they've reached their
full carbon-capture
potential and secondly if you look at
the land surface you see that it's so
heavily utilized we get our food from it
we get our forestry products from it
biodiversity protection air water and
everything else to expect them we'll
find enough space to deal with this
problem I think is going to be quite
quite problematic but if we look
offshore we see a solution where there's
already an existing industry and where
there's a clearer way forward the oceans
cover about 70% of our planet they they
play a really big role in regulating our
climate and if we can enhance the growth
of seaweed in them we can use them I
think to develop a climb
altering crop there are so many
different kinds of seaweed
there's unbelievable genetic diversity
in seaweed and they're very ancient
there was some of the first
multicellular organisms ever to evolve
people are using special kinds of
seaweed now for particular purposes like
developing very high quality
pharmaceutical products but you can also
use seaweed to take a seaweed bath it's
supposed to be good for your skin I
can't testify to that but um you can do
it the scalability is the big thing
about seaweed farming you know if we
could cover 9% of the world's ocean in
seaweed farms we could draw down the
equivalent of all of the greenhouse
gases we put up in any one year more
than 50 Giga tons now I thought that was
fantastic when I first read it I've
heard a better calculate how big 9% of
the world's oceans is it turns out it's
about four and a half Australia's the
place I live in and how close are we to
that at the moment
how many ocean-going seaweed farms do we
actually have out there zero but we do
have some prototypes and therein lies
some hope this little drawing here of a
seaweed farms currently under
construction tells you some very
interesting things about seaweed you can
see the seaweed growing on that rack
twenty-five meters down in the ocean
there it's really different from
anything you'll see on land and the
reason being that you know seaweed is
not like trees it doesn't have
non-productive parts like roots and
trunks and branches and bark the whole
of the plant is pretty much
photosynthetic so it grows fast seaweed
can grow a metre a day and how do we
sequester the carbon again it's very
different from on land all you need to
do is cut that seaweed off drifts into
the ocean abyss once it's down a
kilometer the carbon in that seaweed is
effectively out of the atmospheric
system for centuries or millennia but if
you played a forest you've got to worry
about forest fires bugs etc etc
releasing that that carbon the key to
this farm know is that little pipe going
down into the depths you know the the
the mid-ocean is basically a vast
biological desert there's no nutrients
there that we used up long ago
but just 500 meters down there is cool
very nutrient-rich water and with just a
little bit of clean renewable energy you
can pump that water up and use the
nutrients in it to irrigate your seaweed
crop so I think this is really has so
many benefits it it's um
changing a biological desert the mid
ocean into a productive maybe even
planet saving solution so what could go
wrong
well anything we're talking about at
this scale is involves a planetary scale
intervention here and we have to be very
careful I think that piles of stinking
seaweed are probably going to be the
least of our problems there's other
unforeseen things that will happen then
one of the things that really worries me
when I talk about this is the fate of
biodiversity in the deep ocean you know
if we're putting Giga tons of seaweed
into the deep ocean were affecting life
down there the good news is that we know
that a lot of seaweed already reaches
the deep ocean after storms or through
submarine canyons so we're not talking
about a novel process here we're talking
about enhancing a natural process and we
learn as we go I mean it may be that
these ocean growing seaweed farms will
need to be mobile to distribute the
seaweed across vast areas of the ocean
rather than creating a big stinking pile
in one place it may be that we'll need
to char the seaweed so create a sort of
an inert and mineral biochar before we
dispatch it into the deep we won't know
until we start the process and we will
learn effectively by doing I just want
to take you to contemporary seaweed
farming it's a big business it's a six
billion dollar a year business these
seaweed farms of South Korea you can see
them from space they are huge and
they're increasingly not just seaweed
farms what people are doing in places
like this is something called ocean
permaculture and in ocean permaculture
you grow fish shellfish and seaweed all
together and the reason it works so well
is that the seaweed
makes the sea water less acid it
provides an ideal environment for
growing marine protein
if we cover 9% of the world's oceans in
ocean permaculture we would be producing
enough protein and form of fish and
shellfish to give every person in a
population of 10 billion 200 kilograms
of high-quality protein per year so
we've got a multipotent solution here we
can address climate change we can feed
the world we can be acidify the oceans
the economics of all of this is going to
be challenging you know we'll be
investing many many billions of dollars
into these solutions and they will take
decades to get to the Gigaton scale the
reason that I'm convinced that this is
going to happen is that unless we get
the gas out of the air it is going to
keep driving adverse consequences it
will flood our cities it will deprive us
of food it will cause all sorts of civil
unrest so anyone who's got a solution to
dealing with this problem
has a valuable asset and already as I've
explained ocean permaculture is well on
the road to being economically
sustainable you know in the next 30
years we have to go from being a carbon
emitting economy to a carbon absorbing
economy and that doesn't seem like very
long but half of the greenhouse gases
that we've put into the atmosphere
we've put there in the last 30 years my
argument is if we can put the gas in in
30 years we can pull it out in 30 years
and if you doubt how much can be done
over 30 years just cast your mind back a
century to 1919 compare it with 1950
know in 1919 here in Edinburgh you know
you might have seen a canvas and wood
biplane 30 years later you'd be seeing
jet aircraft transport in the streets
were horses in 1919 by 1950 they're
Motor Vehicles 1919 we had gunpowder
1950 we had nuclear power we can do a
lot in a short period of time but it all
depends upon us believing that we can
find a solution what I would love to do
is bring together all of the people with
knowledge in this space the engineers
who know how to build structures off
or the seaweed farmers the finances the
government regulators that people who
understand how things are done and chart
a way forward so how do we go from the
existing six billion dollar a year
inshore seaweed industry to this new
form of industry which has got so much
potential but will require large amounts
of investment I I'm not a betting man
you know but if I were I'll tell you my
money you'd be on that stuff and beyond
seaweed it's my hero thank you
[Applause]
[Music]